[Applause]
[Music]
chauffeurs
official cars advisors secretaries cell
phones airline tickets
fine offices hairdressers butler
services and
a more than generous salary equivalent
to 15 to 20 times the minimum wage
per month this this is the life of a
visual politics host i'm kidding it's
actually the life of a representative of
the people in a country like
argentina where shockingly almost 50
percent of the population lives in
poverty and where the average salary
barely exceeds 300 a month
in other words my dear friends if you
want to live the argentine dream
you're going to have to dedicate
yourself to politics in the land of the
tango traditional barbecue
and of course financial bailouts and yes
yes
this is another video about argentina a
country that is becoming a bit of a pet
here on visualpolitik but
what can i say as they say in those
parts it never stopped giving us letters
which
means argentina just doesn't stop making
the news its current affairs
are non-stop and my friends it could be
easy to believe
as president alberto fernandez usually
claims that all of this
about the cost of politics is simply a
minor issue or
pure demagoguery of course that could be
the case if argentine politicians were
not
actively responsible for destroying the
country while turning argentina into a
kind of five-star resort for the members
of their own select club and
keep in mind that we are talking about
argentina a place where politics weighs
much heavier than you can imagine
[Music]
you see my friends argentina has been in
a severe economic recession for three
years in 2018 the economy fell by 2.5
in 2019 by 2.2 and in 2020 with the
pandemic as well by 12
and it's not only about gdp practically
all of the indicators
are banned poverty is still on the rise
the public deficit is above six percent
and inflation well as we've already told
you here on visualpolitik argentinian
inflation escapes all economic logic
health crisis or not
the government keeps hitting the money
printing press again and again
and again and again something that
economics is technically called
expanding the money supply to infinity
and beyond
well in spite of all this argentine
politicians have not been able to make a
single solitary gesture
you know demagoguey
i don't know maybe the fact that most
politicians have almost always lived off
the stage has caused them to build
like a shell a wall almost that protects
them from the problems that are
consuming the country because
obviously nothing is ever their fault
despite all this some authoritative
sources such as the economist roberto
chanosky have been calling for a drastic
reduction in the cost of political
structure for some time now a reduction
that would improve the increasingly
deteriorating perception of politics
while relieving the meager public
coffers who knows maybe even reduce the
bureaucratic and political costs
and lower the taxes that affect
productive activities in one of the
countries with the highest corporate
taxes in the world who knows
maybe just maybe that might be a good
idea now
is it really possible to reduce the cost
of politics in argentina what burden are
we talking about exactly what would be
the best way to reduce this expense
and improve its efficiency and a no less
important question
could closing the five-star luxury
resort for argentine politicians
improve the lives of regular argentines
to find out let's get cracking
a multi-layered structure
so first of all a point to keep in mind
between the 1930s and 1983 argentina
spent half of its time under military
dictatorships in a way
that explains why once democracy was
restored in 1983
anything to do with it was inviolable it
simply could not be criticized
that meant any negative comment was seen
as an anti-democratic statement
and politicians as politicians i want to
do took advantage of this however we are
already in the second decade of the 21st
century so
i am sorry but this sensitivity is no
longer valid
criticizing a way of doing politics does
not mean criticizing democracy on the
contrary opacity
lack of transparency and lack of
criticism generate
impunity all of which added together i'm
sure you smart people who watch
visualpolitik will know
becomes the best possible cocktail for
abuse but what exactly are we talking
about here so
look at it this way let's take as a
reference the market exchange rate of
the argentinian peso to the dollar
at the time of making this video the
rate was approximately 85 pesos per
dollar
that would make the minimum wage around
212 dollars per month a policeman's is
per month a nurses is 470 and a
teacher's just over 300
according to the national institute of
statistics and census of argentina among
the employed populations the average
income was 365
and the median income that is the one
that is right in the middle and leaves
fifty percent of the income below and
fifty percent of the income above was
only two hundred
and ninety four dollars as a comparison
the median salary in spain
is about one thousand seven hundred
dollars six and a half times higher and
we are only talking about spain where
salaries are quite low it's really best
not to compare with other countries like
france the united states or canada you
see my friends these figures from the
once
richest country in the world are plain
and simply bleak
but hold on just one minute because the
situation among politicians that is
somewhat different
but rather than focusing strictly on the
data notice how layered argentine
politics has become creating a very
expensive elephant for the public
coffers
to maintain
[Music]
but in order to not complicate things
too much let's focus on the case of the
national congress keeping in mind that
the situation there is similar to what
we can find throughout the rest of the
political bodies in argentina the
national congress of argentina consists
of a chamber of deputies with 257
members and a senate with 72
representatives the budget for the
national congress for the year 2021
is just as much more than 470 million
dollars which means
that each of the 329 representatives
will cost argentine citizens an average
of 1 million
428 to 571 dollars per year although if
we go into detail the cost per senator
is actually much higher than that of a
deputy
obviously these costs include many items
of all kinds such as consultants
catering or i don't know
maybe hairdressing it's true in fact the
national congress has had its own
hairdressings alone at the disposal
of the members of congress which is
something i've been pushing for here at
visualpolitik for a long time
in fact even once they have fulfilled
their mandate under article 9 of law
20.984 they can continue to enjoy
facilities such as the dining room or
the hairdressing salon
in terms of salaries at first glance
things seem less striking the salary of
a congressman or senator is around 2500
a month much less for example than in
spain but don't get too distracted here
remember that we are talking about
argentina a country where the median
salary as i mentioned is 265
in other words the salary of a member of
congress is equivalent to 9.5
average salaries using our previous
comparison it would be like a spanish
congressman earning an average
of sixteen thousand dollars each month
but
apparently that's actually not the worst
of it the most striking thing is that
one thousand four hundred and seventy
people
work in the senate twenty people for
each senator and another 2
161 people work in the chamber of
deputies eight
for each deputy or member of parliament
[Music]
in fact the real cost per deputy taking
into account their own salary
cell phone assistance transportation etc
is about
forty thousand dollars per month sixty
percent more than spain in absolute
terms and in the case of senators the
figures soars to one hundred and forty
thousand dollars per month seven times
higher than the equivalent cost
in spain these are all in absolute terms
a relative comparison is genuinely
better left unsaid and even though spain
is
three times wealthier than argentina it
is hardly a role model of an efficient
public service still it seems like
argentina wins the prize for taking care
of its politicians
the record is held by senator roberto
basswaldo of the allianza cambiemo san
juan with 60 direct
team members he is followed by luis
neidenoff with 48
employees roberto kaczynski argentine
economist
of course as many of you are probably
imagining at this very moment
many of these people are relatives
friends and political collaborators with
few or no professional qualifications
for the very important advisory
work that they are supposed to be doing
and that is not all
[Music]
[Applause]
according to a report by cadal the
center for the opening and development
of latin america the largest staff
increases were recorded in other
areas of legislative branch such as for
example the congressional printing
office which has
according to the 2018 budget 679
employees
18 more than in 2016 despite the fact
that we are in the midst of a digital
era in which paper printing has been
significantly reducing worldwide for its
part the library has more than 1
700 employees 80 percent more than in
2004.
that's 1 700 workers from one library i
would love to know what on earth is they
do
of course it's more than likely that
most of them are simply political
members the big boss
hooks them up and then there they stay
for life faithful public employees
of the worlds i presume best library
[Music]
perhaps most surprising of all is that
according to journalist augustine
corelli even back in 2019
before the pandemic congress barely held
any sessions in either the senate or
the chamber of deputies in short let me
say this it's a real farce
but that was just one example we have
only talked about the national congress
but the truth is is that this model of
expensive
oversized and meaningless structures is
repeated across the board the size of
the state in argentina
is completely out of control and the
result well
the result is what you have already seen
a median salary of 265
estate in constant crisis almost 50
poverty and taxes
are amongst the highest in the world so
in argentina the greatest privileges go
to politicians as we've already seen in
a past video here on visualpolitik which
i will link below take for example the
case of
christiana fernandez de kitchener or cfk
which just saying is making me hungry
and i'm not telling to talk about
corruption here at least
what is not legally understood as
corruption
[Music]
federal judge escuel perez nami
authorized the current vice president to
collect
simultaneously the tax-free life pension
to which she's entitled for having
previously been president
together with the pension of her late
husband also a former president
along with her current salary as vice
president in total more than 24 000
each month
[Music]
that's 100 times the median salary so
do not tell me that she is not onto a
good thing and not only that the judges
also recognized her entitlement to 1.2
million in subsidy back payments what a
sweet
sweet deal argentine politics is but i
can't stress enough that the worst thing
about argentina is not the isolated
cases but the country
model the politicians have built for
their own benefit
for example they have used a political
strategy of buying votes
ad nauseum and today between one thing
and another more than half of the
population receives some kind of direct
or indirect payment
from the state such as salaries
subsidies and pensions more than half of
the population which is obviously not
all that viable and it is not a welfare
state that has been built in argentina
but a state
of poverty in argentina rose to 44.2
and touches 18 million people these are
data from the social debt observatory of
the uca
on the third quarter of 2020. in one
year two million new poor people were
added destitution
totaled 10.1 percent ambito frankly i
know i've been joking but let me tell
you how truly sorry i am for a country
as wonderful as argentina once was a
country that represented the dream of
millions of people who traveled there
from europe in search of freedom and
prosperity the broken dream of what was
once
the richest and most developed country
in the world
as always we hope you really enjoyed
this video please hit like if you did
and don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos
thanks for watching i'll see you next
time and if you want to learn more about
politics and hear
even more of my lovely voice you can
join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider media.com
podcast see you there